suggestions and when this
beckoning from a Shaitan
intensifies what a person
should do, what a person should
say, how a person control his
thoughts when one's demons
begin to rear their head. He
mentions and he starts off this
chapter with a narration which
is collected by Allah and
others on the authority of
Abdullah bin Masood. That the
prophet said that indeed the
angel does hold a position and
has a voice and an insinuation
in the heart of the human being
and likewise, a Shaitan does as
well and so, the suggestions
and the whispers of the angel
in a person's heart
suggestions, and promises of
good suggestions, and constant
reminder to believe in the
truth and constant hopefulness
and encouragement to the human
being to constantly be hopeful
in Allah Allah's reward. He
says, and the Shaitan, he as
well has He is well holds
whispers and does toss
suggestions into the human
being's heart. And those are
most notably when we boil them
down, they are usually
suggestions of disbelief in the
truth. And hopelessness. And so
the prophet says if you
experience the suggestions of
the angel in your heart, then
praise Allah. And ask Allah for
good. And if you find yourself
experiencing in your heart, a
suggestion from a Shaitan, then
seek refuge in Allah. and seek
his forgiveness. So here, we
see that the human being does
not only have a devil, a
Korean, that whispers and
incites evil to a human being
but as well, the human being
has angels that Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala has placed in his
life to continue to suggest and
beckon to do good things, to
think good thoughts, to believe
true things. It's mentioned by
some of the scholars, some of
the companions, the Taberian,
that the angels that are
commissioned by Allah to write
down our deeds. So, we have an
angel on the right and an angel
to the left. These angels are
to document our good deeds and
document as well our bad deeds
that these angels not only
collect and write and document
meticulously what the human
being says or does but as well
these angels the angel to the
right writes our good deeds and
also suggests to us and
encourages us to do good things
and the angel to our left that
is commissioned to document our
misdeeds not only does that but
as well warns us and tries to
suggest us away from committing
acts of sinfulness, and to
avoid disobedience of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
[Silence]
to the point that he describes
the intensity of a Shaitan's
whispers to him in his prayer
as being intense that a Shaitan
has essentially come between
myself and my prayer and
recitation. You know, what
shall I do about this? The
prophet responded and said,
that whisper that you
experience in prayer
specifically comes from a very
particular type of demon or
devil who is known as Kinzeb
and so if you start to feel
this scattering of thought and
excessive whispers in your
prayer, seek refuge in Allah
and blow to your left three
times. This is what a person is
to do if they find themselves
being assailed by a Shaitan
with whispers in their prayer.
This of course, all of these
things that the prophet tells
us to do or say, to seek refuge
in Allah from this or to ask
for this, these things. if they
are done, they have to be done
by the person with total
surety, and total belief in the
promise Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. The promise of the
messenger of Allah Sallallahu
Alai that indeed if I do this
and if I follow through with
this properly in the way that
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has
commanded and truly believing
in the promise of Allah that I
shall be responded to and my
dua will be answered. This is
what is meant. Not just that a
person go through the motions.
Just having
doubt whilst having doubt in
Allah's promise. Yes.
In salah, yes. Now, in
[Silence]
to weaken his faith and Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. Shaitan
may present himself in a
person's heart as the person
himself. And will whisper to a
person things that will induce
hopelessness and induce
hesitation in belief in Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala in the last
day It's mentioned here that
the companions complain to the
prophet about these whispers.
Meaning, they would find that
leading thoughts, whispers,
would antagonize them in their
heart, in their minds would
kind of overtake their
thoughts. Things that are
unspeakable. And so the prophet
[Arabic recitation]
and praise to Allah that he has
reduced the Shaitan's efforts
to mere whispers.
One of these common occurrences
is that a person will
start to have doubts about
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala about
the prophet about the Quran,
about the religion of Islam,
about many things in this vein
in this regard and so a person
is to fight these thoughts head
on And a lot of this entails
dismissing these thoughts. Many
people get caught in this trap
and they can't seem to find a
way out. They have these
thoughts. They have these
feelings, and they try to do
one of two things. Number one,
they tried to debate these
things and come to a resolution
Or number two, they dwell on
these thoughts and are scared
of these thoughts. To the point
that people will say things
you know, I'm I'm afraid
that I'm a disbeliever but I
actually want to be a believer,
right? This is actually
contradicting the statement
itself is contradicting. For
person wants to be a believer,
they will be a believer. These
fleeting thoughts will only
become permanent, a permanent
fixture in a person's mind if
the person dwells on these
thoughts too much. The prophet
gave us an example of this. He
said that a Shaitan may come to
a person and whisper to him
saying, who has created such
and such, who has created such
and such, and the person will
reply, Allah is the creator,
and then a Shaitan will whisper
to a person, this is so what
about Allah? He created
everything, who created him?
The prophet said that if a
person has this thought, that
to seek refuge in Allah and to
cease these thoughts. What do
you mean cease these thoughts?
Meaning not to dwell on them.
These are not your thoughts.
People will confuse these
things as being their own
thoughts. And they're not their
own thoughts. Whispers from a
Shaitan. And a person needs to
dismiss them. Sometimes a
person needs to learn. Maybe
they're having a hard time
because of a lack of research
or a lack of knowledge. And
they could come a resolution
but oftentimes, these whispers
are beyond resolution in the
person's mind. These are just
antagonizing thoughts that a
Shaitan presents to a person to
weaken his resolve, to weaken
his belief in Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. And so, usually
people try to either debate
this issue in their mind which
is not a good idea, because a
person trying to do is, they
will often fail to do so
because they do not have the
appropriate knowledge necessary
to debate this issue or maybe
they don't have the proper
understanding to debate this
issue in their mind. Or second
of all, a person starts to
dwell on these thoughts and
they allow these thoughts to
scare them. They allow the
whispers of a Shaitan. To scare
them. and these are two things
that a person must avoid at all
costs. When these thoughts come
to a person, they have to
dismiss them and they have to
make sure that they not allow
these thoughts to scare them,
scare them into thinking that
they're their own thoughts or
these things are valid or that
these things have. that these
things have any consequence
with Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
They do not. Allah Allah has
pardoned the human being for
fleeting thoughts. Person is
not held accountable for
thoughts that are fleeting
through their mind, that are
unintentional, as long as
they're not dwelled upon, as
long as they, as long as they
are not believed, and held as
true beliefs.
then mentions a common, a
common example of this. He
mentions what's called the
is a is kind of a logical
fallacy. that's been brought up
throughout the centuries,
throughout the millennia,
really, and that is,
you know, this idea that every
creation has to have a creator,
every effect has to have, a
cause. And so, if we go and
trace every effect back to its
original cause, say Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala is the
ultimate creator. He's the
ultimate cause of all that has
happened. And so a person may
then question, well, who
created Allah? Subhanahu wa
ta'ala. But this question is a
fallacy. Because Number one, We
don't have to necessarily
understand something completely
for it to be the right answer.
right? What does that mean? So,
for instance, When we as
Muslims say, Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala has no cause. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala has no no
creator. He has no beginning,
right? This is a valid answer.
Do we understand it completely?
Do we understand the concept?
Really, vividly, understand the
concept of an infinite
beginning, not having a
beginning ever. We can't really
understand something that
because it's not something that
our minds can compute. We we
have no example of that. It's
very unique to Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. It has he has no
beginning. He just always was.
Right? but just because we
can't understand that doesn't
mean I mean, we understand what
it means but we don't
understand how that is Doesn't
mean that that's an incorrect
answer. It doesn't mean that
that invalidates that as being
a valid answer. It's a valid
answer. And I'll give you an
example of that. Let's say for
instance, that
Now, we went to
Let's say for instance that we
went to the moon or went to
another planet. Just just an
exercise here in thought. and
we found on the moon all kinds
of machinery and equipment
Clearly made by an intelligent
being, right? I don't know,
ships or vehicles or anything.
We find all kinds of equipment
over there on the moon. It's
not equipment from Earth. It's
not equipment made by human
beings. What is the logical
explanation of this equipment?
The explanation of this
equipment is that some
intelligent being has put this
together and put it here, left
it here.
Some intelligent being has made
it and put it here. Left it
here on the moon. We don't know
who it is. We know it's not a
human being. We just, there it
is, right? That's the
explanation. That's a valid
explanation. That explanation
doesn't need an explanation for
it to be valid. I don't need to
prove who brought it and how
they brought it and who they
are in order for that to be a
valid explanation. It's valid
because that's the only answer.
that can be produced. I don't
know who those if I can't
identify those intelligent
beings that left this
equipment. It doesn't
invalidate my answer that this
was left by someone who's not
human. You understand? So, just
because something isn't
necessarily something we can
completely wrap our minds
around, doesn't make it an
invalid answer. It's valid. and
so, The point here is that a
person sometimes is unable,
oftentimes, unless they've
studied and have the tools to
be able to debate or discuss
these issues. Most people don't
have the tools or maybe they
don't have the understanding or
the knowledge necessary to be
able to find a resolve to these
kinds of issues. A person and
should
never find themselves
Feeling that if they don't have
the answer, it's must not be
right. That's not correct.
There's a lot of things that we
don't have the answer to. As
individuals but we hold these
things as being truths and
that's correct. And a person
doesn't have to completely
understand something for it to
be beneficial and for it to be
valid and for it to be of
consequence.
[Silence]
Allah
Al
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has
commanded us to deal with these
two types in two different
ways. The whispers and
beckoning and urges of a
Shaitan that is of the of the
spiritual realm. One is to seek
refuge in Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. and as for the evils
the human
a person is to deflect this
person's evil, to respond to
others harshness with kindness,
with forgiveness, with
overlooking in order to avoid
conflict. This is in the vast
[Arabic recitation]
emotions, very potent emotion
is that of anger. And when we
say anger, we're speaking about
unfettered, unbridled anger.
for a person to not get angry,
not become angry, to not allow
anything to make them angry.
This is an impossibility.
Everybody gets upset. Everybody
has insecurities. Anyone can
get upset. And
becoming upset, becoming angry
is an emotional response to
being offended or something of
the sort.
When the prophet tells us not
to get angry. Meaning that we
should avoid the things that
make us angry. We should avoid
situations that make us upset.
and that we should control
symptoms
of our anger when they
arise but the actual emotion of
being angry or being offended
by something, something that
has to be caught, it's
something that has to be
bridled and controlled. But
it's an inevitability. It's
going to happen. And human
beings are very good at pushing
each other's buttons. Very good
at being offensive. Very at
manipulating one another
especially when a person is
dealing with a kind of passive
aggression. This is something
that can be absolutely
infuriating. It can almost
drive a person insane. and
there's a lot of other things
that people do to emotionally
wound one another and in our
society, you know, physical
fighting isn't really something
that is looked at as being
prudent. It's something that's
looked down upon and
confronting people face to face
is something that most people
avoid but most people resort to
passive, aggressive techniques,
and preferred to as gaslighting
and things that and a
person has to learn how to deal
with these things without
allowing himself to be taken
out of character not allowing
himself to get out of
character. This is a
discipline. It's something that
a person has to practice. You
have to practice controlling
yourself and the more you
practice, the better at it
you'll become. and the less you
practice, the more your this
discipline will slip.
controlling one's anger is
Discipline just a muscle.
The more a person practices it,
the stronger that muscle
becomes, the better at it
they'll become. It doesn't mean
that a person will never get
angry or a person will never
act out. And that's a
misunderstanding. A person
needs to be number one, avoid
the things that make them
angry, if at all possible.
Number two, try to control
one's anger in the in the heat
of it. Number if they slip, if
they react badly, then they
need to be quick to repentance
and quick to
damage control if you will.
This is all a person can do and
we as human beings are very
emotional creatures. We're
emotional before we are logical
in most cases. So, it's
important for a person to
practice this and to try to
discipline himself with this as
much as possible. The prophet
gave us some advice with
regards to dealing with some of
these traits of anger, Some of
these misdeeds that may come up
when a person becomes very
angry. We'll discuss these more
next week. Because this is a
very important chapter. It
needs to have a lot of
attention. And inshallah that's
enough for tonight.
Muhammad A